- My dirt is
I'm super not
interested in being fancy.
I'm willing to work,
I work harder than
everybody in this room
and I swear on my fucking life
I'm positive.
Because you can only tie me.
And so, I'm just not fancy.
I'm gonna win and
I'm gonna continue to win
and I'm gonna be
real fucking big
and I'm never gonna
forget what I'm about
and I like getting my hands
dirty and I'll answer that email
and I'll stop and
have that conversation
and I'll take that pitch
and I do unscalable,
not the right use
of my time shit
50% of my day, every day
for the rest of my life
'cause I love the fucking dirt.
I love the grind.
I'll never get fancy.
I don't like fancy
and so that's important to me.
Because, I apologize, because
because, and I want to clarify
one thing about the dirt
because it's important,
'cause you need
to be a practioner
to be good at what you do.
I don't want to
be a social media guru
that reads a headline from
somebody else's tweet.
I know every fucking thing
that Musical.ly, Snapchat,
Vine, Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram does.
Period.
And I sit with all these gurus
that sell fucking books too
and all these fucking
social media experts
and corporations and start ups,
I sit with fucking Facebook and
Instagram in meetings
where their
executives are wrong.
I'm a fucking practitioner.
I really know my shit.
And that's important,
if you want to win,
you have to be able to do that.
And way too many
people lose that.
They forget what
gets them there and
they're not keeping up with it
and the thing that
I do for a living is hard
'cause these platforms
are changing every day,
every second and a
lot of things change.
And the things that
were tried and true
a week ago change
and in that arbitrage,
in your headline reading,
I make money.